At two hours and 15 minutes, Bohemian Rhapsody
is certainly not a short movie, but there
are still a stack of amazing songs and scenes
that were cut from the final film.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here
and in this video I'm revealing and explaining
seven cool scenes and songs deleted from the
new Queen biopic!
Keep watching to the end to find out why the
filmmakers cut some of the epic Live Aid finale
and make sure you subscribe and also leave
a comment about the movie for a chance to
win one of these cool Bohemian Rhapsody merch
packs.
While early scenes in the movie show us how
Freddie Mercury first met and formed a band
with guitarist Brian May and drummer Roger
Taylor, there was another scene filmed that
we never got to see and that was how bass
guitarist John Deacon became part of the group.
Tim Staffell was Smile's original lead singer
and bassist, and in the film he quits the
band the same night that Freddie meets Brian
and Roger.
There's a line where Brian asks Freddie if
he also plays the bass, which he doesn't,
and then there was meant to be a follow-up
scene showing how the band found their new
bassist, John Deacon.
Actor Joe Mazzello, who plays Deacon, says
they shot a proper introduction for his character,
where he was approached by Queen to join the
band while he was at work soldering.
I can see why the scene ended up getting scrapped
in order to keep the story moving forward,
but Mazzello says he wished the scene had
made it into the film as he feels it shows
what an "accidental rock star" Deacon was.
In real life, Queen had several bass guitarists
before student of electronics John Deacon
met May and Taylor at a social event in early
1971 and shortly after successfully auditioned
for the band.
Throughout Queen's history, Deacon has been
regarded as the quieter, more reserved bandmate,
and he retired from the music business in
the late 1990s.
In the movie, when Queen first meet their
new manager John Reid, he tells the band what
he can do for them, including getting them
on the radio, then maybe the TV show Top of
the Pops, and if that goes well, a promotional
tour of Japan.
Cut to the band singing Killer Queen on Top
of the Pops, followed by a montage of stage
performances which includes a little bit of
footage from the Japan tour.
But Ben Hardy, who plays Roger Taylor, has
said there's an additional deleted scene set
in Japan which features the band playing the
song '39, and it was actually one of Hardy's
favourite days on set.
'39, which appeared on Queen's fourth album
A Night At The Opera, tells the story of a
space traveller who goes on a year-long journey
but when he returns, discovers many more years
have actually passed and his loved ones have
died.
The song was written and sung on the album
by Brian May, but in live performances, Freddie
usually led the vocals.
After the charismatic frontman died, however,
Brian has often sung it as part of a tribute
to Freddie, and I suspect in Bohemian Rhapsody
the song was meant to foreshadow in some way
what would happen when Freddie passed away.
I imagine the song was eventually discarded
from the film though as there was still so
much to cover in Queen's story at this point.
By the way, in reality, Queen had already
toured Japan and appeared on Top of the Pops
before John Reid became their manager in late
1975, though they did tour Japan again in
1976, this time under Reid's management as
part of their A Night At the Opera tour.
Indeed, as you might expect of a movie, much
of Bohemian Rhapsody plays fast and loose
with Queen's real-life story and I talk more
about that in my other video; I'll link at
the end and in the video description.
A famous bit of Queen history that was cut
from the film was how Freddie Mercury composed
the catchy, Elvis tribute song Crazy Little
Thing Called Love in just 10 minutes on the
guitar at the same time as he was in the bath!
Rami Malek did shoot that scene, which sounds
like it would have been a fun little moment
in the movie, but it ended up getting the
chop.
Based on the movie's soundtrack album, it
looks like the scene was meant to appear between
the tour scene featuring the song 'Now I'm
Here' and the scene where Freddie shows Mary
Austin video of the crowd singing 'Love Of
My Life' on the band's recent tour.
Freddie Mercury's wilder side is alluded to
in Bohemian Rhapsody with several scenes of
his partying, however, the movie keeps things
strictly PG-13.
According to Allen Leech, who plays Paul Prenter,
though, the snippets we see in the film of
Freddie visiting the Meatpacking district
in New York, and specifically the gay bar
and sex club Mineshaft, were originally part
of a longer, separate scene which also continued
outside the club.
In the final film, clips of the Mineshaft
scene are intercut with scenes of the band
in the studio recording Another One Bites
The Dust.
The filmmakers haven't said why they cut this
scene, but Brian May and Roger Taylor were
producers on the film and have spoken previously
about how they were keen for the movie in
general to really emphasise Freddie's musical
talent over other aspects of his life which
have so often been the focus of tabloid gossip.
Lucy Boynton, who plays Mary Austin, has said
that several of the scenes she shares with
Malek's Freddie Mercury were trimmed in the
final film in order to keep the story moving
forward at a decent pace.
Also cut from the Mary and Freddie scenes
is how Mercury came up with Queen's logo and
more on why he renamed the band from "Smile"
to "Queen."
There's a remnant of this moment in the final
film where Freddie and Mary talk about the
meaning of the new name "Queen", however,
what was chopped out is how Freddie came up
with the band's famous emblem.
So we missed out on Freddie explaining that
Queen's logo is made up of the band members'
zodiac signs.
There's 2 lions, one for Roger Taylor and
another for John Deacon, who are both Leos;
a crab for Brian May's sign, Cancer; and two
fairies for Freddie's sign, Virgo.
Freddie placed those together with the letter
Q which contained a crown, and topped it all
off with a Phoenix.
While the need to keep up the pace of the
movie means casual fans might not realise
the emblem's origins, hardcore fans at least
will doubtless have noticed the brief glimpse
we got of Freddie's sketchbook with various
potential designs he was working on.
Two of the movie's highlights are when the
band records Bohemian Rhapsody together in
the studio and the film's climax when they
perform an incredible set at Live Aid.
What we hear in the movie during that big
on-stage sequence is Bohemian Rhapsody, Radio
Ga-Ga, an Ay-Oh crowd singalong, Hammer to
Fall, and We Are The Champions.
Now, if you're a big Queen fan, you'll know
that, in real life, the band also performed
another two songs at Wembley that day: Crazy
Little Thing Called Love and We Will Rock
You.
And Rami Malek and his co-stars did actually
film the whole of that roughly 20-minute Live
Aid set, including those two songs.
However, as the film was running long and
We Will Rock You had already appeared earlier,
it didn't make the final cut.
I suspect Crazy Little Thing Called Love was
cut from this part of the film for the same
reason, however, because the filmmakers also
ended up cutting the scene where Mercury composes
that song, in the end, Crazy Little Thing
Called Love was missing from the movie.
Interestingly, the Live Aid sequence was the
first thing they shot, so Malek and his fellow
actors were really thrown in at the deep end,
which makes it even more amazing that they
did such an outstanding job bringing that
massive event to life.
And let's face it, Malek and co certainly
had a lot to live up to as Queen's performance
that day has frequently been labelled one
of the greatest live rock performances ever.
I don't know about you, but I'd have happily
watched the cast perform both Crazy Little
Thing Called Love and We Will Rock You again
during that final sequence, so fingers crossed
that we get to see the full version of the
Live Aid gig on the Blu-ray.
Now, do you think any of these deleted scenes
or songs should have been in the movie?
And what did you like best about the film?
Let me know what you think in the comments
below and remember to subscribe for a chance
to win one of these cool Bohemian Rhapsody
merch packs.
Tap left to learn about the biggest changes
Bohemian Rhapsody made to the real story of
Queen or tap right for another video you're
sure to like.
Let me know if you enjoyed this and a thumbs-up
or a share is hugely appreciated.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!